foreign
[Music]
with new evidence in the case of two men
who police say went on a New Year's Eve
murder spree these videos helping us
learn more about how police track down
their two suspects it's a story you'll
only see on 8 news now the i-team's
David charns here with the new video
yeah Brian Denise we obtained several of
these videos in this case that left two
people dead at different crime scenes up
and down the strip investigators saying
the same car you saw in those videos and
a traffic stop weeks before LED them to
their Suspects four separate videos
seemingly show the same thing a BMW with
California plates rolling through a
parking garage police say the two men in
that car are 20 year old jasani Carter
an 18 year old Jordan Ruby seen here
moments after police took them into
custody we talked to Carter in jail
after his arrest so so you're saying
that police have the wrong person
for sure for sure for short for sure
okay you got driver's license but police
say they have the right person they say
this is Carter in this body camera video
driving the same car in November oh this
is my girlfriend's car he was driving
without a license and had been reported
missing police say Carter is also
wearing the same hooded sweatshirt in
this video this one from a robbery the
day before in the wind parking garage
you know just kind of crazy
other video evidence includes the
shooting of 66 year old clarissia
maguchi next to a car near the entrance
to Fashion Show Mall there was a
struggle over her purse and then another
struggle when yamaguchi's husband tried
to tackle one of the suspects the second
homicide that day is not shown on camera
but a security guard is seen biking
through a garage after hearing gunshots
the same BMW leaving seconds later on
its way to Bally's that's where police
say the pair got a bite to eat before
getting cuffed you know wouldn't make
sense for someone to Rob kill three
people
order food hang out with their cousins
like it's a regular day well prosecutors
also say Jordan Ruby told his mother in
some Jail phone calls that he was the
driver in those incidents not the
shooter when we talked to Carter in jail
he said he was the driver both men have
pleaded not guilty I'm David charns live
local now